thank you it's very bright but we like
to keep it bright I love this it's so
rock and roll thank you look at this
with the shoes I know because I am two
feet tall okay I am five three and a
half I'm not that you're way taller than
me wait how tall are you really five two
okay okay yes yeah but I do cheat I
cheat I know so we've always I've run
into a few times I know you know uh
Robert but I I um we never had you on
the show yet I can't I was like I was
like how many seasons have you done they
were saying this is before I know four
seasons
time flies I know I mentioned uh the
things that you do whenever I introduce
you but I left one out I heard that you
are a pickleball club owner yes I do own
a pickleball Club
yes I've never played me neither
what
I don't wait you've never played no I
figured you could teach me okay no I
played paddle tennis
ping pong or well paddle tennis is um
not normal tennis no it's like in a
smaller court and has Glass Walls it's
not racquetball okay I was gonna say and
it's not pickle it's a lot of sports in
there yeah that we mentioned okay I know
I know I've never played either I've
heard it's really fun though it is super
fun and pickleball is super fun from
what I gather yeah
um I like watching it I watch it those
players are crazy good okay so these are
like you go and watch because it's not
like a beginner's thing no no these are
professional pickleball oh yeah yeah I
own a league down down in Santa Monica
yeah no this is like a professional
League it just started okay okay big
thing anybody play I want to try I've
never tried everybody talks about it we
should try
we should do it next time okay we are
both from Texas I know you miss it I do
I missed the Tex-Mex that's what I
missed I miss a Tex-Mex
um but I'm moving home I'm moving back
to San Antonio oh you are yeah oh I love
San Antonio yeah but you're from I'm
from Fort Worth yeah yeah you're from
the north yes it is it is different but
I love I love San Antonio it's a great
City they did such a great job like just
it's an easy City to walk around like I
don't see a lot of places in Texas it's
a driving Place yeah okay like but in
San Antonio I feel like I could walk
everywhere it's like Austin you can walk
a lot of places it's also I mean the
best Tex-Mex is in San Antonio and and
South
um but or in Fort Worth whatever and
I don't know okay even even he's like no
and he's texting yeah thank you I'm a
Texican so I know I'm a text again
I love it I just love the runny queso
that's what people don't get yeah it's
the melted queso the melted cheese
versus the runny queso yeah I have no
time for any queso that's not runny I
know a lot of cheese and Tex-Mex yeah
now I live part-time in Mexico City now
oh I love Mexico as well yeah Mexico
City and the food is obviously yeah very
different and my husband's Mexican and
I'm Texican and so we fight all the time
like he's like I got so much cheese I'm
like yes exactly join me won't you yeah
all right it's so good hence the reason
it's so good no I do like authentic
Mexican food yeah yeah there's it's
amazing the the diversity in Mexico food
yeah yeah
um why so you're there often you're in
Mexico yeah like half the time we're
half Mexico City half Los Angeles that's
awesome now we're going to be Mexico
City San Antonio very cool that's a
quick trip um so what's your favorite
thing about being there in Mexico City
what's your favorite thing Mexico City
yeah oh uh every the food I'm I mean
everything my life is about food I have
no problem mentors around food and uh
yeah the cultures a lot of museums and
in the cultures really celebrated there
like you land and you go yep yep I'm
yeah I'm shopping there is fun I love
everything about John chefs Music
Theater all of it it's just a really
beautiful country very very cool so wait
and you're you're now part of Spanish
nobility right so this is it is it dama
Longoria now I am lady Longoria
I will introduce you from now on what
does this mean it's like it's like um
you know one of the highest honors you
get from Spain this is from Spain so my
family originally is from Spain oh right
so
um so is this to do with your ancestors
yes with my ancestors so there's like
Caballeros and Damas and so now I'm dama
Longoria that's so cool do you get into
that like about ancestors yeah my mother
got really into it I was like you're a
little weird about it and then I got
weird about it I think it's cool too
have you done the well I did it before
because I I don't know why but like many
reasons I won't stay on TV but but I I
ended up I ended up because we're all
getting swabbed all the time so I was
like whatever so I did the 23 being all
the ancestors yeah I found all this
stuff it's cool I mean it's great for
for health indicators exactly yeah
predisposed to Alzheimer's or DeMent
like it's good it's interesting though
that your sibling is different from like
that different from you like going from
a different percentage Yeah a parent
it's yeah it's like they get more of a
gene than yeah you get yeah I'm
basically adopted so
I'm the youngest of four girls and I
look nothing like my brothers and
sisters and I mean I have no brothers
what am I talking about yeah so you
don't look like them I don't look like
them like them either
four girls one bathroom yeah oh my God
okay okay Poor Dad that was like me on
that the only Intel I have on that is
whenever I was on American Idol they had
us live in a house like 20 years ago and
all the girls were just I'm just a very
I'm a tomboy and so I don't wear makeup
if I'm not working I don't do I don't
just not very girly yeah and so anyway I
there you know it was like fighting for
her makeup time or bathrooms or whatever
that's the only Intel I have I was like
oh my gosh this gets hardcore like who
gets in there first you know what I'm
saying it was like I was always happy to
like not even make time for it but
anyway
your son is now four and I hear he
corrects you when you're speaking
Spanish is this true oh yeah he's four
he's four okay he's flew because he's
he's his first language is Spanish I
didn't grow up speaking Spanish yeah
because we live in Mexico City I was
just shooting in Spain he's super fluent
and he corrects me all the time and he
does it with like attitude he's like
disgusting mom and I'm like what you're
for easy easy I'm disappointed yes I'm
so disappointed in my Spanish it's way
easier it's so cool that he's learning
at such a young age it's easier yeah you
know dialect all of that is easier to
pick up then so he sounds very wise for
his age he's super smart okay he he's
brilliant
um
so both of our mamas were teachers were
you a good student
but I felt like I had to be in like my
mom she was like in the time in the
moment she was so annoying because she
would like go to the school for
everything and she would go and ask my
teacher why did she gonna be I read this
feels like an A and yeah my my daughter
needs to be in that class and she needs
to be on this track and so to have a mom
like that advocate for you at school is
super life-changing and important
looking back now so God bless all the
teachers in the world yeah um yeah so I
ended up being a great student because
because she made me that's amazing my
mom's so angry right now at home yes
yeah I was not a I think the only thing
that kept me in school was the Arts like
I just I I love learning I'm like an
avid learner I love reading I love all
that I just didn't like I just think and
especially having kids now yeah people
like to learn differently like you know
we learn different and it's very hard
for me to sit still in like a desk and
like I'm learning and we still learn
that way is weird I know it's just it
I'm I it was just very hard for me for
like that many hours in a day to be like
yeah a worksheet it's hard for most kids
yeah still and especially like
technology has disrupted so many
Industries every industry Health Care
yeah how we buy stuff and everything but
yet it hasn't quite disrupted how we
teach in the classroom yeah you should
have it should which is interesting
because you thought covet would have
changed out a tiny bit just because we
all were on Zoom but anyway glad that's
not still happening um so let's talk
about your new movie though flaming hot
yeah what what made you want to direct
this
um well the story made its way to me
it's a story about Richard Montanez who
was a janitor who worked at Frito-Lay
and had a huge hand in helping launch
the number one snack in the world which
is Flaming Hot Cheetos yeah
um and it's such a beautiful
inspirational motivational story like
this this guy had the hardest upbringing
and the hardest life he couldn't even
read or write didn't really finish High
School I mean nothing and and and is
super successful today because he had
this Thrive and story and discipline and
he added this insane belief in himself
and so when I read his story and I was
like this happened and it's one of my
favorite snacks in the world yeah
um and because literally every human I
know everybody everybody loves
the first time I ate a regular bag of
Cheetos I was like oh I got a bad bag
you were like disappointed yeah yeah I
didn't know there were they forgot the
flavoring I got the flavoring in this
bag
they were like no that's that's how
Cheetos taste you're eating the hot ones
and I was like what there's normal wrong
and rude why do they sell the normal I I
love the heart of that story and I love
that like how many people will connect
to to this character of like maybe you
don't achieve what Society tells you you
need to achieve to be successful but you
still have it in you to make waves
especially for women when women are told
like well that job's not for you or a
person of color we're like oh you know
opportunities aren't for people like you
yeah love to hear it yeah yeah he was
like he dared to ask why not but why not
me why can't I come up with something
great and why I have a great idea why
can't I be heard and um and I think a
lot of people are going to identify with
that journey and that adversity we've
all bumped up against it I know that
you've directed for years but is this
your first like movie is this my first
movie okay I was like because you've
been doing it for like a decade yeah for
shows right 10 years yeah that's awesome
to make that that jump because it's a
lot it's a lot I love this yes you do
like food
in the film The main character has a
side hustle as a kid uh selling burritos
so did you have a side hustle as a kid
oh yeah I had a lot of side hustles I
had so many side hustles one of the main
side hustle I was like eight and I would
mow Lawns and um yeah did you mow Lawns
yes my dad was like I'll give you twenty
dollars to mow the lawn so I did that
like Sunday and I go can I okay so if I
mow it Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
on Friday my dad's like not my lawn
to grow back yeah it has to grow and you
like I was like oh I just wanted him
ours so then I had to ask all the
neighbors if I could uh mow their lawns
that's smart yeah I I think it's so
awesome when kids like my kids are six
and eight and they still are like how
can I earn money and I'm like okay I'm
like I like instilling that and even
that no like I make them like they're
like I want a toy and I'm like cool I've
given you a lot so you can buy your own
if you want to go to Target right now
and they'll use their own money yeah and
then they're like wait so wait I don't
want that toy it just teaches them like
money management yeah they said one of
the greatest indicators of a successful
adult is not Ivy League schools or if
they went to Harvard it's it's did they
have chores when they were a kid yeah
did they understand I have to do this
and the responsibility of doing
something and so wow my mom did really
well then because I I had so many tours
oh my God I was like the only kid in the
house so I had all of them oh you did
I had a lot of chores too yeah yeah
that's good though yeah it teaches you
responsibility yeah and I always tell my
kids too I'm like you are getting paid
you I'm paying for the roof of your head
oh God you became your mom I am yeah I'm
okay with it yeah I came out all right
so this should be fine
um so what it well that's stupid but
what do you what do you hope people take
away from the movie like the message but
you know I hope they leave I love
everybody who's seen the film feels so
good when they love you you feel so good
and I feel like we don't have those
movies anymore like I love all the
Marvel and all that stuff too but like I
know and I like the big epic too but I
don't want to be like super sad either I
want to feel good I want to feel good
when I watch a movie and I want to learn
something and I think people leave are
going to leave watching this film with
like what can I do that's I think that
people are going to leave this film
going dreaming dreaming yeah and I think
that's really cool and that's that's you
know a really big task and a life
accomplished accomplish it yeah keep
dreaming keep dreaming there's there's
no age limit there yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
guys I'm going
[Music]